got ten years of Justin's hairstyles and  we're asking people to pick their  favorite hairstyle from Justin over the  years  might be the best question or the night  I go with this I just I'm gonna go with  a jheri curl and the pineapple finger  wave that was popular in the hood I  think I like to throwback phrase one  time oh god I have to go with like that  too here that kind of looks like [ __ ]  Robin I like I like the Eminem's mom  spaghetti one it literally looks like  like ramen noodles I was not even aware  of this one right here oh that's like  natural pearls JDT Mickey Mouse you know  I love it's so sweet but it's when you  like found out what a blow dryer does  you know JT can still get it sorry Jeff  the cover your man is fine you know a  lot of women want your man Jessica no  disses back